well President Biden making the same
tone-death mistakes after Hurricane
idalia as he did just weeks ago over the
Maui wildfires the monster swarm carving
a path of Destruction across Florida
Georgia and the Carolinas but Biden just
couldn't resist injecting his climate
change agenda and pretending that his
bizarre kitchen fire story is relatable
there's still some deniers out there in
terms of whether or not climate change
anything to do with any of this and
we're going to need a whole hell of a
lot more money we're not just engaged
this often but this last couple years
with climate change and really kicking
in you guys are going 24th hours a day
ladies struck my house we had to be out
of that house for about seven months I
was repaired because so much damage was
done to the house and half the house
almost collapsed
right on cue Biden's Echo chamber in the
media was ready to blame global warming
for Hurricane Adelia
and yes these storms would be here no
matter what they're part of nature but
with human caused and Amplified climate
change we have upped the ante and given
them extra fuels climate change doesn't
necessarily mean more hurricanes it
means the ones that we do get are bigger
or wetter or have stronger winds
Florida's Republican leaders are
actually trying to make it worse
actively
Governor Ron DeSantis is refusing to
accept 350 million dollars in Energy
Efficiency incentives that Florida is
eligible for under the inflation
reduction Act
Biden is pledging that the federal
government will do all it can to help
and will be visiting Florida on Saturday
morning but where was that urgency for
Hawaii when he was sitting on the beach
in Delaware
did you guys realize that the initial
Hawaii Wildfire response was not that
good or is it just easier for people to
get help from the White House when the
president is not on vacation so your
question is is wrong it's flawed in many
many ways and I would I would I would
advise you to go speak to the governor
and the local and state officials in in
uh in Hawaii so Jesse you're the money
guy you followed the money and I heard
Joe Biden say he wants a lot more of it
yeah a lot more so it is a pyramid
scheme climate change if you think about
you have the media the politicians and
the academics at the top and then at the
bottom you have all of us the taxpayers
so academics realized early on that the
more papers that they put out saying
that climate change was caused by humans
and the world was going to blow up in
two years if we don't do something about
it they were going to get more grant
money from the politicians and so the
media takes these research papers and
then they were support them and then
they get big ratings because everybody
gets scared and everybody gets nervous
and then the politicians scare the heck
out of you and said get rid of Big Oil
we need to go green and then they throw
all of our money around at all of their
donors and all their investors so
they're all making all this money
by telling us something that's not
happening we have this big climate
change whistleblower on last night who
said she's been ostracized because she
reported that maybe the Earth is warming
a little bit but the human impact is
really not much and the fact that it's
warming we got this it's not Armageddon
and she has been smeared as a denier and
all of her grants dried up and no one
wants to talk to her in the scientific
Community anymore because that's when
the money stops if you start telling the
truth so terrorist isn't bringing up the
climate change agenda in this scenario
especially in the aftermath of the Maui
wildfires where we saw things like they
didn't let the water out because they
wanted to focus on water Equity isn't it
really a cop-out because they're just
placing the blame on climate change
instead of on maybe government human
error which they could prevent in the
future the magic word you said right
there was equity this Administration is
an administration of equity which means
you pick people for the way they looked
and not on a resume and of course every
time something hits the fan to be polite
they don't know what to do and they make
horrible mistakes and their cover-up is
to Jesse's wonderful point that is the
pyramid scheme because here's the deal I
just bought land in Montana right and I
was excited and I asked why I was
walking around my land I was like wow
there's a lot of dips and trips in the
hills and a lot of Rockies like yeah
Montana used to be under a glacier yeah
right and it was when it was colder and
it was wetter and then the Earth changed
and it got hot and the ice melted away
and now we have these wonderful lakes
and rivers see the thing about Mother
Nature is she never goes oh don't change
this because there's people there that's
our ignorant arrogance and they can't do
anything about climate change if you
start digging in Arizona you're going to
find seashells eventually because at one
time it was under the ocean Earth is
moving and changing and it gives zero
blanks about what people are doing or
saying if you build a dam and build a
city eventually Mother Nature
something's going to happen that damn's
going to break because Mother Nature
doesn't have time for this but they know
they can't do anything about it but why
not make money take away the old money
and help the transition of wealth in
this country by saying you know because
according to them there's no more polar
bears left but their numbers are up
exponentially so you know but again all
this is irrelevant because according to
LC we've got one year six months and
like 12 days left so horizontal is
actually under a notion eight different
times but our president is incompetent
and it's embarrassing judge I find it so
interesting to watch the preparation by
Governor Ron DeSantis and the need to
have linemen available with trucks with
diesel fuel and generators with natural
gas to prepare for a hurricane which is
completely the opposite of what the
climate agenda calls for right it's the
opposite of what we saw on Maui I mean
you know they were not they were not
releasing the water in fact they they
didn't have a plan to shut down the
power lines when there was a brush when
there was brush on the ground but what's
so fascinating about this is one of the
first hurricanes reported was I think it
was in the 1400s now I would venture a
guess that had nothing to do with fossil
fuels okay but there's there are
certainly convinced that we've got
something to do with all of this and
then the other issue is you know
Wildfire season oh it's terrible it's
because it's man-made the Wildfire it's
because of climate change but I should
say I mean to say it's man-made it's
really about arson it's about poor
Forest management it's about making sure
or not making sure that the brush that's
on the ground it be ends up meeting a
power line I mean all of this stuff can
be handled if we at least recognize as
Rhonda santis is recognizing that you
can prepare for it you can plan ahead
and you can be ahead of the game but
claims that that hurricanes and
wildfires are the result of climate
change and the hot weather hot weather
happens in the summer I mean it's that's
just the way it is not in England it
doesn't yeah
so appears you know there is a big
difference between pollution and not
wanting pollution and stopping pollution
and the climate change agenda and for
Joe Biden to bring it up in these
situations it's a political agenda so
he's really just bringing up well he's
not he's really struck actually by the
difference between his response both and
Maui and then again to the hurricane in
Florida and that of Rhonda sentences is
running for president because he might
end up potentially being in the White
House on the one hand you have a guy
who's currently got the job didn't want
to comment originally about maoris I
found extraordinarily tone deaf I have
no comment to me about one of the worst
natural disasters in modern American
history he didn't want to leave his
holiday and go down there when of course
any normal person is that scale of
disaster we're gonna go straight on a
plane just for the Optics never mind
anything else
um and now now he wants to make it all
about himself on this weird fire that
went on in his house which seems to get
progressively worse the only fire known
in history that's got steadily worse
year after year after year since it
actually was put out
um by contrast to santis I've been
really impressed I think he's just
basically said forget politics put all
that to one side he got up at four
o'clock in the morning and he kept
pounding that beat he was on television
all day now part of it might be
self-interest it's obviously good optics
for him running for president but also
it's why he's so popular as a governor
and why he's been so successful he'd get
stuff done and he didn't play politics
he welcomed the president calling him he
talked about that but nowhere did I hear
him blame anything and what's happened
down in Florida is really interesting
three people dead so far way way fewer
people have died than they were
anticipating maybe because the
preparation that went on by Governor
DeSantis and his team was exemplary and
there's a lesson for Joe Biden stop
politics do your job all right there'll
be plenty of time for the politics on
the campaign Trail hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else